was haben kay one und rolf eben
gemeinsam sie benutzen die gleichen
mittelchen um ihren mann zu stehen das
jetzt im fragen lotto mit dem
82-jährigen und er verrät wo er den
ungewöhnlichsten sex hatte das ist das
fragen dazu zwar haben wir uns überlegt
welche gemeinden und welche harmlosen
fragen stellen können
die roten sind richtig gemeinde fragen
und die grünen sind wirklich harmlose
fragen sie können selber wählen nur
rot-rote na logisch ok und dann so
abdrehen am ende genau das ist ja so
lange sich überhaupt an
sie sind alt und reis würden sie ohne
geld überhaupt eine einzige frau
bekommen heute nicht mehr dass wir sehr
schwierig 100 prozent wenn sie wenn ich
sie nicht verwöhnen kann und wenn es
ihre wünsche erfüllen kann und ohne geld
geht das gar nicht
monika gabriel ja auch noch die ein oder
andere abkriegen ja gut der hat ja
seinen namen als sänger und künstler
haben auch war es gleich bei den damen
ist schon ein sehr gutes rennen ich
meine grund tag da wo er kann ist zum
beispiel eine freundin die sie will ihn
aber er will
da weint sie mir immer was vor wie
gesagt bei ihnen können sie alle haben
oder wie freiheit also es gibt sehr
viele die es nicht haben kann das war
immer schon dass man nicht alle hängen
aber weil es dass man muss sich wirklich
anstrengen wenn man eine wirklich haben
will dann darf man das auch wenns jahr
dauert oder 2310 nicht loslassen des
mannes ist dann kaputt
deswegen muss man dranbleiben bis es
eventuell klappt und dafür ja ja
wenn du mir wirklich gut gefallen hat
für uns nicht nur eine eintagsfliege
sein sollten
so sind sie überflüssig oder selbst
verliebt haben sie überhaupt echte
freunde also oberfläche ich bin ich ja
nicht selbst verliebt bin ich sehr ich
liebe mich sehr sehr tief und wollen ab
gab kürzlich sogar genau ich liebe mich
sehr und echte freunde habe ich nicht
glaube ich nicht weil das ist nicht
meine sache da besten freundin verliert
man so viel zeit sondern immer brauchen
sie nicht manchmal traurig wir hatten
die nieten paul ii ich habe keinen grund
zwar ist mir auch alles was traurig ist
von mir extrem gut wir haben noch eine
rote werden rote worden
das reicht wir können auch gerne mal
eine grünen entziehen wie sie wohl mal
so gesagt das sind so lang weil die
sachen ja die sind aber diese auch
schwer zu beantworten
also obwohl sie sind ja selbst verließ
die fans wahrscheinlich bar sorgen ja so
was haben wir hier sex sex und party
sind ihr lebensinhalt dann geht das noch
ohne wundermittelchen manchmal nicht
dann haben wir natürlich ein paar mittel
sind die ich dann immer natascha habe
und man muss ja immer bereit sein
allzeit bereit also es ist so was ist
mir dann was war der ungewöhnlichsten
orten wo sich schon mal festhalten dass
wir überlegen ich hab so viel sex gehabt
das ist mein leben und überleben
naja im flugzeug also auf der toilette
im flugzeug auf der toilette im flugzeug
schöne sache weil es so viele leute gibt
es ja nicht im flug zerstört keiner
meistens ist ja auch appel aber kriegt
man nicht ins blaue flecken nur das
könnte sein aber ich habe keine gekriegt
okay kommt noch eine grüne einer
schweren zeit
sie können sich eine aussuchen
wie ist es dahin kommen können sie
drehen version
angeblich hat noch nie jemand schlecht
über sie geredet
außerdem nehmen wir gerade im community
video außerdem vom community video ist
das wahr oder haben sie diese leute nur
angst die wahrheit zu sagen das weiß ich
nicht da müssen wir die leute fragen
würde was ist ihr eindruck gibt nichts
schlechtes über mich ich bin ein
wunderkind nur gut ist gutes ist okay
dann haben wir das also bleibt ich hoffe
es aber vielen dank das war ein
richtiges vergnügen müssen
das freut mich sehr richtig gut jung
immer ziemlich lustig dass fragen lotto
bei pixum auch das mit kultur die
erzählt wie man durch pizza zu
lebensfreude kommt also eine vollkommen
neue methode stadt yoga oder sonstigen
wie das geht im fragen auto mit ihr und
sehr interessant und lehrreich das mit
dem rapper nazar der erklärt warum er
immer noch so was wie dragon ball z und
batman guckt und batman dies nichts
verhindert das könnt ihr bei ihm lernen
und jetzt soll ich ja immer ein bisschen
zeit lassen denn mit euch zwischen dem
oder dem video entscheiden können ich
versuche ein bisschen neutral zu gucken
wenn ich niemanden beeinflussen